european union leaders have endorsed new
plans to tighten defense cooperation
improve military capabilities and inject
new life into the defense industry the
leaders discussed ways to develop use
and share assets together to help Europe
better defend against modern security
threats even as pressure remains high on
military spending the approach back to
the summit in brussels by nato secretary
general anders fogh rasmussen includes
boosting the efficiency and visibility
of EU missions abroad the leaders
announced plans for countries to work
together on remotely piloted air systems
or drones satellite communications
air-to-air refuelling and cyber defense
it's hoped that the projects will create
new jobs and spark more growth in the
industry in international affairs the
council expressed concern about the
crisis in Ukraine where thousands of
people have been protesting since the
government declined to sign a major
partnership agreement with the EU the
leaders underlined that the offer of
signing the association agreement and
trade pact remains on the table and that
Russia should not feel threatened by the
arrangement the association agreement
and the free trade agreement we are
offering is in the long-term interest of
Ukraine to get to have a modern
independent free Ukraine based also on
the rule of law during the meeting
praise was given to France for its
efforts to help avoid a civil war in the
Central African Republic the leaders
expressed deep concern about the crisis
and they've tasked High Representative
Catherine Ashton with presenting a
proposal on ways in which the EU can
help on financial matters the leaders
welcomed recent moves on building a
banking Union which will help to keep
struggling banks of float or wind them
down without major economic consequences
the project including supervision and
resolution mechanisms supported by a
deposit guarantee for citizens faces a
vote in the European Parliament
hopefully before its term ends in May